今夜から
我々のチャンネルぜ
新企画
強い花させるぞ
始めようと思います
ああああああああ
この企画は
視聴者さんから頂いたああ
強い話すようですねそれを我々で
より強く
語り
伝えていこうそうです
今回新たに
江衣花ずシリーズぞ
始めさせていただきます
というわけでぜひ皆さん
強い話せがあったら
こちらですね
あなたの
アカウント名と
怖い話の本文を送ってください
開け皆さんが怖い話
小松していますお願いします
ってはまあ初回は
この
kazu 3冊は僕がねまぁパッと
なものを言っちゃおうと思います
御在位ますね期待してる方飼っ
ああああああっ
これはですねあ
北
たのを聞いてる聞いたことある人も多いと思うんですけど
ネットとか友達ってから
聞いた話なんですよ
どんな話かというとなんかこういう例というものは
0とかそういう悪霊とだっていうのはまあいい
何カッ
水
水目
水が多いところに集まりだすんですよね
よく一番我々の身近にあると万羽ヅルトイレと洗面ずっと
を通りで洗面ぞあと風呂場とかフロー
そういうところにバレーっていうのはつまりやすい傾向がありますけど
でなんか聞いた話によるとダイバーさんがころんだっていうゲーム知ってますか
あの後ろを向いてそうです神社とかそういう
ところでこう
小さい子はそんな奴だよね子供がよく遊ぶ
あそれがあるんですけど
だるま歳の頃だってくれるぞ
絶対言ってはいけないところですよ
黒子ばです
いやべてお前のかやー
これから俺を風呂バターさぁさぁ
じゃあ何でも仲間たちで黒マネーえっ
そのだるまさんがころんだということを言ったらまずがむらいます言ってよ
行っても何が起こるかこれないんですよねー
話なんであの皆さん本当に気を付けて下さいねそういう
風呂場で画廊さん転んだって言っちゃなんですよまずやめたほうがいいかちょっとふざ
けっ
でしょ絶対そうですよねざわじゃないぞこの中でありますから騙されちゃいけませんだ
けど皆さんこんな感じでもどんな話でもいいんでまぁそこはんっ名古屋話ぜひ待って
ますお願いしまーす
どうぞそれじゃ
こんな感じで
こんなところにこんな感じで続け酔う
none
ウントっ